my name is Harold McGee and I'm here
today not to tell you how I became a
scientist but how I decided not to
become a scientist and still ended up
publishing papers in nature and physics
today except that the subjects were the
the making of souffles and the the
flipping of steaks on a grill so I grew
up in the Midwest in the 50s in a
brand-new subdivision where there was
still plenty of nature around and the
skies were dark and I grew up immersed
in that fascinated by it and was
especially fascinated by the Stars so I
wanted to be an astronomer and my father
had gone to Caltech we had alumni
magazines on the coffee table all the
time and Caltech ran Mount Palomar
Observatory which at the time was the
best so Caltech it was and I went there
Caltech is a science and engineering
school it's a very small school couple
hundred students in every graduating
class and that meant that the class
sizes were small as well and that meant
that I was able to really get to know a
number of wonderful professors including
people in the humanities departments we
had to take philosophy and literature
for for breadth and what I discovered
was after the first couple of years of
Caltech boot camp where everybody takes
physics and math and chemistry and we
got into our specialties that I was
really getting more interested or less
interested in the nuts and bolts of
astronomy the physics of astronomy and
much more interested in what astronomy
did to our sense of ourselves as
creatures on this planet that is to say
I got more interested in the humanities
courses within the astronomy courses so
much soul-searching I was difficult to
do because nobody at Caltech
really majored in the humanities I
decided to switch gears and to apply for
transfer to a liberal arts school my
teachers at Cal Tech convinced me not to
do that and it was the humanities
professors who said look you came to Cal
Tech because you love science you still
love science you just love it in a
different way and we'll make sure that
you get a good education in philosophy
and literature and if you stay here you
can take courses that you'd never be
able to take anywhere else from the
scientists who are here so that's what I
did and I was able to do things like
study the synthesis of the elements in
stars from the guy who figured that out
back in the 50s and 60s and it was an
amazing experience the best decision I
made I went from Caltech to Yale to do a
PhD in literature and I wrote a
dissertation about John Keats a Romantic
poet and then for a couple of years
while I was looking for a tenure-track
position I taught full-time at Yale
everything from remedial writing to the
epic tradition from Homer to James Joyce
and I loved it it was great that's what
I wanted to do with my life
but then as now tenure-track positions
were scarce and I didn't have any luck
for a couple of years running and so I
began to think maybe I should
recalibrate here what can I do maybe I
can kind of recoup my investment than
rediscover my love in science and make
use of what I learned about words by
teaching literature and teaching writing
and Yale and write about science and
maybe write about the science of
everyday life which not many people were
doing my girlfriend at the time gave a
an informal class at one of the colleges
on the chemistry of fudge making and it
was a huge success people couldn't wait
to eat the demonstration afterwards
and so that gave me the idea that maybe
writing about food and cooking might be
an interesting thing to do what sealed
the deal was when I mentioned this to a
friend of mine a fellow faculty member
who said if you're gonna write about the
science of food and cooking I've got a
question for you
I'm from New Orleans I love red beans
and rice I can't eat more than one
serving of beans without suffering for
it and so what I want to know is what is
it in beans that makes me suffer and is
there a hierarchy of beans some beans
that are more painful than others is
there a fart chart that I can refer to
to make my life easier and I thought it
was a great question and that sent me
off to the library to see if I could
find an answer and I went to the Food
and Agriculture section of the Science
Library where I'd never been before and
discovered the world of food science
which I had no idea existed and which it
it was clear after a few hours of
browsing was this amazing trove of
information knowledge micrographs that
just they blew my mind and I thought I
have to tell the rest of the world about
this stuff in addition to that I was
able to find the answer to my friends
question but I also discovered that the
people who had funded much of the
research on flatulence was NASA because
they were concerned about air quality in
space capsules so that taught me that
not only was there interesting
information useful information out there
there was also a lot of fun to be had
with the subject and so again some
soul-searching because I was leaving a
job with a paycheck I decided to quit
teaching and tried to write a book about
the science of food and cooking not food
science but kitchen science and I did
that with no training in either field I
didn't know anything about food science
I didn't know anything really about
culinary arts I cooked at home but
that was it that might sound like a
tremendous disadvantage to start from I
didn't think about it at all that's just
the way it was and in retrospect I think
was actually a great thing because not
knowing anything about either field if
that meant I had no preconceptions about
what either field should be or could do
and no preconceptions about what
questions were respectable questions or
interesting questions or questions that
could be answered and that I think made
it possible for me to write the kind of
book I did it also led me to
experimentation stuff that I hadn't done
since I'd been at Cal Tech and labs so
for example I read in Julia Child that
you should when you're making an egg
white foam to make a meringue or a
souffle you should use a copper bowl
because copper bowls give you a better
phone and that didn't make any sense to
me I went and looked at the food science
literature on protein foams there was
nothing nothing in there that was
relevant but I did the experiment I
tried side-by-side eggs whipped in a
copper and glass bowl and regardless of
the chemistry involved they were
tremendously different just different in
texture and color in the amount of time
it took to get the foam in the first
place and in how long it lasted so I
wanted to know why that was food science
literature wasn't any help
so I rounded up a couple of scientist
friends one of whom had a
spectrophotometer that we could use and
we came up with a hypothesis we tested
that hypothesis we wrote a kind of
tongue-in-cheek paper and submitted it
to nature and nature sent it through its
regular review process and it passed
with almost flying colors the one
qualification that one reviewer made was
the science looked fine but the subject
was fluffy
so nature went ahead and published it a
few years after that I wrote with some
physicist friends a paper about
simulating heat transfer on a computer
through foods and discovered thereby
that the faster you flip a steak or a
hamburger on the grill the faster it
cooks through significantly faster and
the more evenly it cooks through I would
never on my own have thought of flipping
steak
every 15 seconds if a computer hadn't
told me that it might be a good idea and
it turned out that it's a good idea so I
had tremendous fun with the experimental
side of this project as well as just
delving into food science proper my book
was published in 1984 and it kind of sat
there for a few years because you have
to remember that was a long time ago
that was pre specialty coffees pre
extra-virgin olive oil
pre balsamic vinegar pre personal
computer when it comes to doing the
scholarship so it took a while for
people to see that the science of
cooking was an interesting subject now
25 years later it's actually fashionable
chefs are celebrities and water baths
and and thermocouples have made it from
the lab into the kitchen and the the
study of the the science of cooking has
become of interest not just to cooks but
the scientists so my book is now being
used the second edition of it it's being
used in courses not just at culinary
schools but at universities I'm a
visiting lecturer at Harvard I'm a
visiting scholar at UC Davis my books
been translated into half a dozen
languages and I get to speak to people
all over the place about the subject so
it's it's definitely true that I am NOT
a professional scientist I still don't
have tenure but I have my own library
card and I get the chance every day to
share the excitement and the fascination
of science with lots and lots of other
people it certainly and all
turn ative career but it's a wonderful
alternative and I think there are lots
of alternatives like that out there
you